today I'm going to demonstrate how to
program a remote for a 2012 Hyundai
Sonata using the autel km100
we're going to start by going into the
immobilizer menu
where we will select Hyundai
now I do manual selection with this tool
just out of preference
where's the car at not where it's made
so we're in America
you'll notice especially on the Hyundai
and Kia models there seem to be a bunch
of options you got onto Sonata there's
just a ton of them this is a 2012 it's a
blade key
so we're going to go it's probably this
last one here yep 2011 through 2014
blade key
yes that is the vehicle
so from there we're going to go to hot
function
oh I'm sorry we're going into control
unit
remote system
remote control learning
turn ignition on then off
so I'll show you that it's wanting the
instrument screen black ignition on then
off
also says to pull the key out
so we'll pull the key out hit okay
lock or unlock for more than one second
now it's hard to hear but you hear a
little chime and it says programming
succeeded so I'm going to hit no
programming is complete
now it's closed out of the programming
mode
here I'll show it with the dash
so there's the remote programming for a
2012 Hyundai Sonata using the autel
km100 thank you